the White House has a fresh fight on its
hands a presidential commission
investigating potential fraud in last
year's election is meeting stiff
resistance from some states to turn over
their voter information our Nancy Cordes
hears from one governor who is refusing
to comply this is an outrageous
violation of citizens privacy rights
Virginia Governor Terry McAuliffe told
CBS News his state will not hand over
sensitive voter files to the White House
McAuliffe joins officials from more than
20 states who say they can't or won't
comply with this week's request for
voter roll data including addresses
dates of birth political party and even
voter history elections voted in from
2006 onward the request came from the
new Presidential Commission on election
integrity established after President
Trump who lost the popular vote insisted
three to five million people voted
illegally you have people that are
registered who are dead who are illegals
who are in two stage GOP leaders have
rejected his claim I've seen no evidence
to that effect New York's Democratic
Governor Andrew Cuomo announced we will
not be complying with this request New
York refuses to perpetuate the myth
voter fraud played a role in our
election Utah's Republican lieutenant
governor said we will not share any
protected data with the Commission even
the vice president's home state
announced that Indiana law doesn't
permit the Secretary of State to provide
the personal information requested the
new Commission is led by Kansas
secretary of state Kris Kobach a
longtime crusader against voter fraud he
says he only wants the data in order to
fully analyze vulnerabilities and issues
related to voter registration and voting
Democrats suspect there's more to it we
will not let Donald Trump and his weight
ring extremists use this as some covert
plan to get data to make it harder for
people to vote we won't stand for a
number of states say they want to help
and we'll provide any data they can
legally share but Mississippi's
Secretary of State a Republican said on
Friday that it's a
violation of voters privacy and said the
commission can quote go jump in the Gulf
of Mexico Mississippi is a great state
to launch rum for CBS this morning
Saturday I'm Nancy Cordes in Washington